in 2012 two years from now
London is holding the Olympic Games and
each year that the Olympic Games take
place the organisers choose a mascot
something that will symbolize their
games and for the last 30 years they
have been little fluffy animals which
are really of no interest at all to
chemists and nobody can remember what
they are either but this time the London
organisers have revealed their mascot
which you can see on the screen behind
me which are made of steel their story
is that two droplets of Steel fell from
the roof of the Olympic Stadium and
miraculously turned into these two
creatures who can have adventures but
the interest for the chemist is in the
steel not the creatures
I think it's a great message we're now
getting some science into what's an
exciting event and will make people ask
all sorts of interesting questions and
if you look at the figures in detail
they have webcams for eyes and all sorts
of things so there's a lot of Science in
them and they may be quite a lot of
opportunity for us to explain different
aspects but today we're going to focus
on the steel steel is an alloy of iron
and there are lots of different Steel's
as I'll explain in a minute but the
problem starts when you make iron as you
probably know that in prehistoric times
people made tools out of stone and then
along came more technologically advanced
tribes
who can make things out of bronze and
then they could start making swords and
things out of iron the real problem with
early swords that were made out of iron
was that they broke very easily and you
can imagine it's slightly embarrassing
you're in the middle of a fight and
suddenly your sword breaks and you're in
quite a vulnerable position if the other
guys sword hasn't broken - and the
reason why I earn breaks is because it's
really quite a soft material and over
the years people have found different
ways of treating iron when you first
make iron out of iron oxide it comes out
as a rather unappetizing lump this is a
piece that Neil and Pete made in one of
their thermite reactions
don't me throw a gun on that so
instantly the thermite reaction starts
and you can see that it's so hot it's
boot a hole through the bottom of that
terracotta flowerpot but if we go in
close no Brady you can see all that
really quite nice molten iron and you
can see it's mucky and generally it
looks not very likely and that you would
expect and originally what people did
was they would take this iron and heat
it up and bang it for ages and ages to
make things like horseshoes and this is
quite an old horseshoe it's rusted a bit
but the point about horseshoes is that
when they were banging them they removed
all of the carbon that was dissolved in
the iron the carbon comes from the coke
the coal that is used to make the iron
they just went on banging the iron on an
anvil till you got rid of all the carbon
and in that case you could easily bend
it to form the horseshoe and you got a
very reproducible material the
breakthrough when making steel was came
when people realized the way to get it
right was to remove all the carbon and
then add some in and this was discovered
in I think the early 19th century by an
English industrialist call Bessemer who
discovered if you blow oxygen through
the liquid iron it will remove all the
carbon the carbon burns before the iron
and so then you end with end up with
pure iron and you can add just the right
amount of carbon and get good steel the
difficulty is that you make good knives
but the knives rust and so you have to
keep on cleaning it otherwise it rusts
and eventually will rust completely away
and the final technical breakthrough
came when people discovered that if you
added other metals nickel chromium to
the iron and carbon in steel you could
then men's stainless steel like the
spoon
stay shiny whatever you do and so now we
have a huge number of different steals
and each steal is used for something
different because each of them have
different properties and if you don't
have stainless steel you either have to
clean it all the time will paint it
which is why on some of the old bridges
that were built in the 19th century like
the famous forth railway bridge in
Scotland people have to paint it all the
time - stop it rusting but I'm sure that
the Olympic mascots are made out of
stainless steel because it's shiny and
nice and they'll be more fun to watch